le plaisir oui de sortir à nouveau en
était placé sur france 3 sous le signe
des retrouvailles à ce midi notre page
et et nous emmène à l'écomusée de la
bresse
après des mois de confinement nous
sommes allés voir comment le secteur de
la culture se remet doucement de la
crise cette année avec emmanuel
pinsonneault et romain les bose
[Musique]
le château de pierre de bresse en saône
et loire c'est le siège de l'écomusée de
la bresse un musée qui accueille une
année normale environ 20000 visiteurs
alors normal évidemment ça n'est pas ce
qui caractérise l'année qui vient de
s'écouler le musée comme tous les autres
étaient fermés c'est au mois de mai que
le public est revenu c'est là que se
sont fait les retrouvailles
on va voir tout de suite avec la
directrice du site comment a été
traversé cette période inédite
c'était comme bonjour alors on sort
d'une période pour le moins particulière
comment est ce que vous l'avez traverser
ou ici au musée on la traverse est
difficilement
il faut savoir que l'écomusée de la
bresse bourguignonne est un est une
association
donc du coup on est subventionné par des
collectivités de l'argent public mais on
a aussi une grosse part
d'autofinancement et forcément quand
toutes les activités s'arrêtent en même
temps et bien ça pose des problèmes
financiers et notamment on a dû mettre
une bonne partie du personnel en chômage
partiel et le reste de l'équipe qui a pu
rester sur place a essayé de mettre en
place des activités type hors les murs
contenus numériques etc pour essayer
quand même de continuer à proposer des
choses au public mais c'est vrai que la
période a été difficile on arrive quand
même à tirer un profit quelconque d'une
période comme comme celle ci dans un
musée oui on arrive quand même à trouver
des avantages et on se rend compte quand
même quand un musée est fermé au public
le sens de nos métiers se perdent très
rapidement certes on conserve une
collection on conserve un patrimoine
mais si on n'a pas la possibilité de le
transmettre et de le diffuser au public
tout d'un coup il ya quand même un peu
quelque chose qui s'en va y est le
deuxième avantage c'est quand même que
du coup il ya eu une période de creux en
termes de travail et qu'on a pu se
mettre à des réflexions de fond et
notamment l écomusée sur des questions
comme par exemple l'avenir de notre
structure travailler sur des des travaux
de recherche scientifique qui avait
toujours été mis de côté à cause un peu
voilà du foisonnement de la vie pour
parler de manière générale et c'est vrai
que ça a été un peu le deuxième avantage
c'est un peu ce temps de pause qui nous
a permis à nous
de faire des choses que d'habitude on
n'a pas le temps de faire quand on a
rouvert au mois de mai on savait pas du
tout à quoi s'attendre on était un peu
inquiet mais finalement c'était
peut-être des inquiétudes infondées
puisque on a quand même eu pas mal de
visiteurs et les histoires individuelles
sont quand même au rendez vous un peu
plus que l'année précédente mais en tout
cas ils sont là c'est sûr que rien
visité du tout pendant nous qui sommes
habitués à faire des châteaux etc
sa banque et donc c'est bien qu'elles
soient ouvertes aussi à personne donc
c'est encore mieux pour marquer comme il
est actuellement même un peu tranquille
voilà l'écomusée de la bresse en fait ce
n'est pas uniquement le château de
pierre de bresse le château de faire de
vraies ce n'est que le siège d'un réseau
beaucoup plus vaste
onze sites qui sont sur l'ensemble de la
bresse bourguignonne et chacun des sites
en fait et plus ou moins une émanation
du château de perdre de pierre de bresse
et présente des thématiques de manière
plus approfondie qu'on peut le faire au
château et parmi les différents sites de
l'écomusée de la bresse il y en a
particulièrement vivant et qu'il manque
pas de caractère de caractères
d'imprimerie en local
[Musique]
mais ici dans les anciens locaux faute
du journal l'indépendant sa-7 bureau du
rédacteur en chef c'est le plus grand
comme d'habitude
[Musique]
oh
et on arrive ici à l'imprimerie où nous
a tant de beauté royaux dorothée bonjour
bonjour alors la particularité de ce
musée c'est qu'en fait il est venu lui
s'installer sur le site d'origine
c'est ça donc c'est un musée in situ
donc effectivement avec le musée est
venu s'installer à l'endroit même où
autrefois on a imprimé le journal de
l'un des pontes toutes les machines et
les presses fonctionne encore vous
pouvez nous montrer constant depuis
[Musique]
voilà c'était le bouclage de la
prochaine édition de l'indépendant et ça
nous permet par la même occasion de
boucler cette page et et merci beaucoup
merci